qu'est ce qu'un ennemi chez les
autochtones oui bienvenue à paroles
autochtone si ces milices au moulin
depuis sept semaines pour répondre à la
question de françois sur qu'est-ce qu'un
aîné chez les autochtones
d'ailleurs les autochtones encore le
grand père mme panier dépendant de la
nation un nenê ça va être la personne
cac qui a acquéri le plus de ses gestes
bien sûr maintenant on va calculer aussi
lâche ça va dépendre de certaines
nations ou être un aîné ça commence à 50
ans et d'autres à 65
mais pourquoi est ce que le terme est né
et si favoriser chez programmation
souvent parce que le traitement des
aînés chez les premières nations est
beaucoup plus je tirais honorifique
favorable ils vont manger en premier
lors des festins et on va écouter leurs
paroles parce que leur expérience de vie
vont bénéficier à toute la communauté
c'est sûr que c'est difficile de faire
le contraste en un aîné non autochtone
est un ennemi autochtone parce que c'est
souvent ce que je voyais mossé mahomet
les aînés dans des maisons résidences
pour personnes âgées et je savais
pourquoi pourquoi les gardes pêche et
une chez nous beaucoup lire apparent
pour être central et on va bâtir une
maison nous campement autour de nos
grands parents
donc ils sont encore très présent dans
la vie au quotidien leur avis en
politique était très important donc
c'est surtout ça c'est c'est un citoyen
qui a participé toute sa vie à la vie de
la communauté et son avis son expérience
valoriser énormément d'ailleurs je pense
que ça aide à voir la proche de la
vieillesse comme quelque chose de
favorable et non comme quelque chose
d'abominable ou ou la fin triste d'une
belle vie moi je dis souvent parce que
je suis un aîné en formation parce que
j'ai hâte à ce moment à l'autre parce
que je mange en premier parce qu'on va
me coûter plus parce que c'est une
position qui montre que tu as participé
à ta communauté donc tu comprends qu'un
aîné ça va dépendre de chaque nation
mais le rôle est toujours aussi
important et
à paroles est toujours autant écouter
bien sûr on s'entend qu'il ya des
ennemis que sont pas aussi sage que ça
donc on peut faire la distinction
mais chaque expérience de vie est
importante et d'ailleurs une expérience
de dénis qui avait été partagée dans le
livre de mathieu mistoco source était
telle personne avait été ridiculisé
pendant des années jusqu'au moment où ce
qu'il a atteint le statut des aînés et
là il est devenu quelqu'un qui était
intégrée dans la communauté et qu'on
respecte et parce que peu importe son os
son histoire il avait du vécu et
l'expérience en espérant avoir répondu à
des questions françois lespérance vous
allez partager cette vidéo je souhaite
une très belle semaine